where's Optimus Prime
[Music]
I want the beetle work here every day
for a year Josh kid do you speak only
person you can show yourself around his
knee so let's say we're driving and all
of a sudden somebody's alright you
serious
I'm gonna see if I can fix it and pray
this message find you our war rages are
life-threatening the voice mentioned of
water
you're hiding from something
the criminal is hiding on us our common
enemy isn't found goober the whole
planet
the EU 120 syllables you must protect
your earth and its people
thank you
do not run
she rap
bumblebee what have you done I am so
screwed I'm Charlie Watson I'm 18
today actually it's the beetle for sale
yours kid happy birthday
[Music]
what are you
so you have no idea where he came from
no idea
[Applause]
well here's the deal people can be
terrible about things they don't
understand from now on the only person
you can show yourself around is me oh
good now I'm good thanks
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way sir anyone that can
help you or the family Oh
they're calling an army
I've seen firsthand these things really
are
bumblebee there is only one way to end
this war you must protect earth and its
people
this is how we stopped
you've cut me
and I'm not going anywhere
you